[Musique]
peu d'entre vous connaissent pierre
boussel et le mouvement pour un parti
des travailleurs et pourtant c'est dès
novembre 1987 que le mouvement pour un
parti des travailleurs a décidé de
présenter pierre boussel comme candidat
à l'élection présidentielle
c'est donc un véritable boycott qui a
été organisée pendant cinq mois par tous
les médias nationaux
pierre roussel employés de la sécurité
sociale est aujourd'hui retraité il a 68
ans militant ouvrier syndicaliste depuis
l'âge de 16 ans il est l'un des
principaux fondateurs du mouvement pour
un parti des travailleurs notre
mouvement a été fondée en 1985 par des
militants qui appartiennent à toutes les
sensibilités du mouvement ouvrier parti
socialiste parti communiste français pcf
syndicalistes militants laïques
tous ont constaté que françois
mitterrand et ses gouvernements mauroy
fiterman puis fabius ont trahi les
espoirs de 1981 et permis ainsi le
retour de la droite
voilà pourquoi le mppt combat pour
construire un nouveau parti
un véritable parti des travailleurs
derrière les mots il y a les faits nous
allons donc parler de fait les faits
c'est le rapport de la commission des
sages sur la sécurité sociale
actuellement déposés au conseil
économique et social par le gouvernement
ce rapport sur lequel le consensus est
totale et dont personne dans ces
élections ne parle
regardez le film qui va suivre la
sécurité sociale les droits des assurés
sociaux sont attaqués
le ministre se garent à supprimer le
remboursement à 100 % des maladies
nécessitant des soins longs et coûteux
643 mille personnes en sont les victimes
deux millions et demi de grands malades
également car le remboursement à 100%
est réservé à la seule maladie figurant
sur une liste définie par le
gouvernement
l'hôpital est désormais interdit aux
gens qui ne peuvent pas payer les 300 à
900 francs par jour
leur demande et pour le lendemain des
élections
le rapport dit des sages préconise de
libérer le prix des médicaments est
donné rembourser coteaux unique de 50 %
il suggère encore de supprimer des
services hospitaliers et des hôpitaux
entier enfin pour la retraite
il faudrait avoir cotisé 40 ans pour
pouvoir la prendre j'ai demandé à madame
le docteur martin 2 bat médecin conseil
à la sécurité sociale
révoqué par monsieur le ministre séguin
d'en expliquer les raisons je suis
médecin conseil de la sécurité sociale
depuis 16 ans j'ai d'abord été suspendu
de ses fonctions puis licencié cela fait
maintenant cinq mois qu'ils mettent
interdit d'exercer nos professions
pendant 16 ans j'ai été notés comme un
très bon médecin conseil mais avec le
plan seguin ce sont de toutes nouvelles
directives qui ont été données aux
médecins conseils en voici un exemple
j'ai reçu l'ordre de convoquer au
contrôle médical
une malade né en 1895 et ceci pour
remettre en cause le droit ou 100 % dont
elle bénéficiait
une dame une malade âgé de 92 ans
comment aurais-je pu lé a convoqué j'ai
refusé
et puis j'ai refusé d'établir la liste
nominale de mes confrères médecins
traitants accusé de ne pas respecter le
plan seguin
tels sont les motifs de mon licenciement
j'affirme qu'aucun gouvernement n'a le
droit d'imposer à des médecins des
tâches contraire aux règles de leur
déontologie
le devoir des médecins consiste en toute
circonstance et en premier lieu à
défendre l'intérêt des malades
en aucun cas ils n'entrent dans les
fonctions des médecins conseils de
supprimer les droits des assurés sociaux
en fonction de normes économiques
je tiens à remercier
les professeurs milhas et guérin ainsi
que mai 2000 confrères de toutes
tendances qui demandent ma réintégration
comment et pourquoi le plan seguin en
descendent 1985 man du foie ministre
réforme par décret le code de la
sécurité sociale
monsieur seguin ministre a ensuite fait
adopter cette réforme du foie par
l'assemblée nationale
et il ya les problèmes relatifs aux
allocations familiales des faits en
voici voilà ce qu'on lit dans le rapport
de la cour des comptes
on assiste à un net ralentissement des
dépenses de prestations
le nombre des bénéficiaires est donc le
montant des prestations diminue et c'est
la tragique situation des handicapés les
malades atteints de poliomyélite exclu
par monsieur seguin du remboursement à
100% les 6000 enfants sourds également
exclue à 100% je passe la parole à marc
gauclin membre du bureau national du
mouvement pour un parti des travailleurs
il n'ya de notre part aucune volonté de
règlement de compte lorsque nous
rappelons le rôle des ministres
bérégovoy khalid et georgina dufoix
mais ce sont eux qui vont voir la voie
monsieur ce lien prenons la loi
hospitalière de 1983 elle est signée
khalid et bien vous voir elle instaure
le budget global
le forfait hospitalier jusqu'ici vous
aviez droit l'hospitalisation dé leur
que votre étals nécessité
ce n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui j'ai
ici un document officiel
il s'agit du règlement intérieur de
l'hôpital beaujon voici ce qu'on peut y
lire
l'admission du malade est subordonnée au
paiement d'une provision égale à dix
fois le montant des frais journaliers
restant à sa charge
si le séjour se prolonge la provision
doit être renouvelé tous les dix jours
c'est à peine croyable si vous n'êtes
pas à 100 %
s'ils voulaient par couverts par une
mutuelle alors il vous faudra payer pour
entrer à l'hôpital
payer 3000 francs en service de médecine
5000 francs pédiatrie 9000 francs a
service hautement spécialisés et si vous
ne pouvez pas payer lorsque monsieur
seguin refuse de recevoir une délégation
de milliers de personnes qui manifestent
le 24 mars pour le rétablissement des
100 % pour la réintégration du docteur
débat pense-t-il qu'il peut faire
disparaître le problème
il aurait tort de croire nous sommes
sûrs que le travailleur de ce pays ne
laisseront pas perpétré ce crime contre
la santé mouvement pour un parti des
travailleurs
nous ne voulons qu'une chose aidés par
notre action le vaste mouvement qui
réalisera l'unité des travailleurs et
des organisations contre toutes ces
mesures la médecine scolaire elle même
est remise en cause
la tuberculose fait sa réapparition dans
les écoles abordant ensemble les
problèmes de l'école
c'est vrai avec mes collègues nous
sommes très préoccupés tous les
ministres part de l'échec scolaire
mais tous les ministres ferme des
classes par milliers dans toute la
france chaque année ils à ce point de
vue je comprends l'inquiétude des
parents mon fils entrent à l'école
maternelle au mois de septembre
eh bien il a fallu que je commence les
démarches il ya un an
ma fille doit rentrer au collège en
sixième à la prochaine rentrée
c'est pareil il a fallu commencer les
démarches il ya plus d'un an un collège
entier ayant été fermés le pour
l'ensemble des familles le suivi de la
scolarité devient un véritable parcours
du combattant et une très grande
angoisse
pour nous l'important c'est que les
enfants apprennent bien à l'école
l'école doit rester l'école ce qu ils
n'apprendront pas à l'école ils ne la
prendront nulle part ailleurs
mon poste a été supprimé comme des
dizaines d'autres postes de collègues
enseignants ont été supprimés alors que
des milliers d'élèves sortante cinquième
demande chaque année à pouvoir rentrer
en lycée professionnel
en fait on nous retire nos élèves on
supprime nos postes pour livrer des
jeunes à des stages tuque et civp
en fait en les livrant la
surexploitation des patrons
[Musique]
on a fait la grève pour le retrait du
projet devaquet ya un an et demi
et aujourd'hui on constate que c'est la
même politique qui s'est tenue diplômes
locaux qui sont liées au patronat et qui
ne valent rien sélection à l'entrée en
licence sélection pour les bacheliers
qui rentre à l'université et ses
orientations et sans mise en place par
des conseils
quelle que soit leur couleur politique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jamais côté laurent jacquemin étudiants
et michel ceyrac enseignants à qui je
passe la parole
on nous promet de tout côté la priorité
à l'éducation le temps bien sûr d'une
campagne électorale
c'est tellement facile pour la droite
elle a gouverné pendant 25 ans et si
j'en crois les statistiques de monsieur
moon heures il lui même il y a
aujourd'hui 25 % d'illettrés dans nos
classes de 6e 1 % d'illettrés par année
le gouvernement
c'est un bilan c'est le bilan de toutes
ces réformes prétendu qu'ils ont
disloqué notre école publique de ces
milliers de fermetures de classes
d'écoles rurales de tout ce avec quoi
nous avons voulu finir en 1981
mais vous savez ce qui s'est passé avec
le gouvernement de gauche ces réformes
c'est loi haby debré guermeur ont été
consacrés on a continué à verser les
fonds publics aux écoles privées
patronal on a recommencé à fermer des
écoles on a entassé les enfants à 30 35
40 dans les classes on a même autorisé
l'empiètement d' influence politique
d'intérêt privé dans les écoles au
mépris de leur si précieuse neutralité
et puis il y a
ces dispositions terrible contre
l'enseignement technique cette loi qui
porte le nom de monsieur carraz ministre
socialiste mais qui permet aujourd'hui
nous l'avons vu à monsieur monnerie de
fermer des classes conduisant à des
diplômes professionnels alors que tant
de jeunes veulent pas prendre un vrai
métier alors priorité à l'éducation oui
en abrogeant toutes ces réformes
en recrutant sur le champ ses milliers
d'enseignants qualifiés normalement
payés qui font cruellement défaut on
viendra peut-être nous dire il n'y a pas
d'argent
comme c'est curieux il y a toujours de
l'argent pour les crédibilité
il y a toujours de l'argent pour ses
placements financiers qui finissent dans
le gouffre des tracks boursiers il n'ya
jamais d'argent pour l'école laïque
priorité à l'éducation certainement mais
en inversant totalement la politique
suivie sans interruption depuis 30 ans à
la remise en cause de nos droits
c'est ça l'enjeu aujourd'hui constate
par fac les conseils d'université
multiplie les barrages
la sélection entre les cycles quand on
continue de créer des diplômes locaux
sans valeur quand chaque année on
empêche des milliers de bacheliers de
s'inscrire librement dans l'université
la filière de son choix
alors est-ce qu'on peut encore parler du
droit aux études égale pour tous et
qu'on soit étudiants lycéens élèves dlp
tuque chômeurs
de toute façon on est dans le même bain
on est dans le même bain parce qu'on
veut nous marginaliser on est dans le
même bain parce qu'on veut nous
marginaliser pour nous priver de nos
droits de ces droits que nous parents
ont arraché alors on nous fait des
discours on nous parle de la formation
de l'éducation de l'insertion dans la
vie professionnelle
on nous parle du réalisme le réalisme
c'est qu'on ne peut pas vivre avec 1200
francs par mois
le réalisme c'est qu'aujourd'hui on peut
être tuque jusqu'à 25 jusqu'à 30 ans le
réalisme ce qu'on peut pas se loger avec
1200 francs par mois
on peut pas fonder une famille avec 1200
sont par mois mais nous ne sommes pas
résignés parce que nous avons appris à
nous défendre nous avons appris via un
an et demi nous avons fait
l'apprentissage dans la grève générale
de la démocratie avec nos comités de
grève nos délégués élus et mandatés et
révocables à tout instant alors ils
peuvent toujours parlé nous comme de la
génération de l'an 2000
nous nous savons ce que nous voulons et
c'est simple ce que nous voulons c'est
pouvoir étudier ce que nous voulons
c'est pouvoir travailler avec un vrai
travail
ce que nous voulons c'est pouvoir vivre
pas survivre
vivre il faut que la vérité soit dite
le savez vous en raison du budget global
instituée par monsieur bérégovoy
ministre socialiste par monsieur khalid
ministre pcf ont prescrit actuellement
aux médecins aux infirmières aux
travailleurs hospitaliers de gérer
l'hôpital comme une entreprise
le malade étant considéré comme un
client
vous savez un client qui n'a pas
d'argent ne peut acheter les
marchandises
un malade qui ne peut payer ne sera donc
plus soignée voilà les conséquences des
mesures prises depuis 1982 et cela c'est
la vérité il ya eu rupture des
engagements pris en 1981 il faut une
autre politique sur le mensonge
rien de valable ne peut s'édifier
[Musique]
et